la dernière phase des travaux du pont
schuller est enclenché la nouvelle
partie du pont a été bétonné par les
ouvriers une épaisseur de 70 cm coulé
sur le tabou gay il ya des équipes qui y
vivre le béton que le béton écoute sur
vibrer pour faire sortir les bulles
d'air et il ya d'autres équipes qui sont
en train de faire le talochage qu'on
appelle couramment des dalles agissent
et
on pourra voir pour avoir une surface
vraiment liste pour rappel cette partie
du pont sera destiné à la circulation
des bus dans les deux sens avec
l'objectif de fluidifier le trafic
routier sur cet itinéraire c'est la
dernière étape
on a vraiment du béton après derrière on
va passer qu'on appelle les finitions
donc la mise en place de l'étanchéité la
mise en place des garde corps
périphériques et l'habillage en termes
de serrurerie dont et pornichet
l'extérieur et donc tout ça ça nous
amène si vous voulez en gros le bon il
serait il ce récit recul avant septembre
les ouvriers entameront à ce moment là
une phase de rénovation du pont existant
la circulation se fera sur la nouvelle
partie de l'infrastructure l'ensemble
des travaux devraient se terminer à la
fin de l'année 2018